and DW correspondent Terry Schultz
attended an exclusive NATO briefing late
yesterday and gave us this debrief of
what was said
so what I've been told by this Western
intelligence source is that they very
much fear that if the pace of the
invasion continues as it has up until
now uh that Kiev could be encircled and
fall to the Russians within 24 hours of
course I mean that is not a 100 percent
certain assessment but this is what it
looks like now from the success that the
Russians have had in taking over the
country all the way to the Capitol they
now control this official says all of
Ukrainian airspace they control both the
military and the civilian airport
in a near Kiev so this of course is a
very very key asset for the Ukrainian
government that has been lost this
official also fears that uh that Putin
does intend to go all the way into the
capital and try to remove president
zielinski and replace him with a puppet
president that would would carry out
moscow's wishes so the assessments are
very very dire at the moment NATO is not
going to go in and and join the
Ukrainian side by side in this combat
today we heard Secretary General
stoltenberg praised the Ukrainian men
and women in uniform for fighting
bravely I think everyone's hearts are
breaking as they watch this but there
simply would never be an agreement by 30
allies to go in and fight for Ukraine
that was never going to happen
is an expert on European security
analyst and a former advisor to the
Romanian government Julia thanks for
joining DW now NATO has stressed over
and over you heard it there again from
Terry Schultz so they will not be
putting boots on the ground in Ukraine
without Military Support is the fall of
Kiev a foregone conclusion
I'm not sure about that I guess it
defines it depends on how we Define the
fall
um yeah we have had news indeed um that
President zielinski and his family are
on the the top of the kill list of
Russia but even if an attack on
high-level officials
um in a Ukraine from Russia would
succeed that would not mean um that Kiev
would fall it would mean that there will
be civil war
what do you think Putin's end game is
then I mean many have speculated
President Biden included that Putin has
plans to restore the former Soviet Union
do you think there's any truth to that
I think there's more than that and I
think people across Eastern Europe in
Ukraine and Beyond have known this for a
long time I think it's other parts of of
Europe and the transatlantic space that
have been grappling with this reality
and didn't want it to be true we've seen
a Russian military aggression against in
the early 90s against Moldova against
Georgia we've seen it again against
Georgia in 2008 we've seen it in 2014 in
Ukraine and now again and if we're
looking back at the so-called demands
that Russia has made to Nato and the
United States they included three points
which share which reveal that there's no
doubt about Russia's intentions one is
Ukraine not joining NATO the second one
is the withdrawal of military
capabilities of the United States from
Eastern European countries these members
of NATO and the third one most
importantly is the reversal of NATO
membership to all members of NATO that
joined after 1997. so I guess at this
point we have confirmed I'm from Russia
that it's not just the Soviet Union is
it's more than that it's Central in
Eastern Europe
there must be a lot of fear then in the
region about countries in the region
particularly those other former Soviet
States preparing for an escalation
Beyond Ukraine
yes we've seen uh the the most clear
signs if you will in terms of
preparation now for many years military
and
um on the non-military side if you think
about the energy decoupling in the
Baltic countries in Poland after 2014
and we've seen of course increasing
worries in all former Soviet Union
countries and again outside of those if
we're looking at Poland or Romania we're
neighboring neighboring Ukraine so
there's a lot of concern there's a lot
of planning taking
um taking place on the ground and of
course there's a lot of military
preparation on the NATO side we see a
little bit of that with an enforcement
of the Eastern flank and maybe some
discussions about the um the launch of
the rapid reaction force but mostly that
is Aid that is being provided just like
we've seen over the last 10 years or so
by the United States whereas aid from
the rest of NATO members to Eastern
Europe is is much more reduced Julie
we're almost out of time but I did want
to just sort of widen that idea of what
are the what are the implications that
this will have for peace and Security in
Europe
well I think at this point even though
again it's hard to Grapple with reality
since yesterday we have seen that Europe
is being bombed we haven't seen that in
a long time and it it begs a lot of
questions if we think back at the Former
Yugoslav wars Europeans have said this
is the hour of Europe and have failed to
keep their promise of European security
and European peace on the continent then
without without American help now we're
seeing that we haven't learned the
lessons on both sides of the Atlantic
and that we have now a situation in
which Europe is being bombed and more is
likely to come in from the western side
we're seeing only discussions about
sanctions and how harsh they should be
Julia thank you Julia yoya European
security analyst